ownership don't let nobody [ __ ] you
kill them $1 mil it's about being free
in this United States of America we know
tyranny when with manatee and we are not
going to take this stinking stinky smell
again Washington DC taxi driver Nathan
price keeps his cab in the basement of
his Virginia apartment building after
driving into the district and picking up
a few fares he generally stops by a
local hangout to meet up with other
drivers price who's now 68 is like
almost all DC cab drivers in
owner/operator who works when he wants
to what's it mean for you to own your
own cab or to be able to set your own
hours as a cab door total freedom and
there's nothing nothing like it I can go
to work anytime I feel like it I can
quit anytime I feel like it so I get a
schedule as to what suits me DC's cab
industry is among the freest in the
nation allowing flexibility for drivers
and relatively open access to thousands
of immigrants who were in their
livelihood driving a cab in the district
this industry was a stepping stone for
free slaves before the Civil War it was
a stepping stone for immigrants from
Europe at the turn of the 20th century
it took my business away from me
you just took the free-enterprise out of
my life that's what we're facing right
now now Washington DC is considering a
bill that would require every cab in the
district to have a permit known as a
Medallia the city would only issue four
thousand medallions cutting the total
number of cabs by more than a third and
putting thousands of drivers out of work
kill the medallion bill
the minority of cabbies who have been
driving for at least five years and live
in Washington DC would get the
medallions first I was born and raised
in the district started driving but the
past 15 years I lived in Virginia I get
a pink slip price would still have a
shot at getting one of those 4,000
medallions since he's been driving for
more than 20 years but only after their
first offer to cab companies who could
then turn around and rent them to
drivers they're being set up to say you
commit to renting which means you commit
to giving up a portion of your earnings
or you get out we don't do that to
anyone in any other profession it's a
scenario that's been repeated across the
country over and over medallion systems
have pushed out individual entrepreneurs
and put them to work for politically
connected companies in Prince George's
County the cab companies rent their cabs
to cab drivers at three hundred and
thirty dollars a week in Montgomery
County upwards of $100 a day they're
working long hours to give more than
half of their earnings to the medallion
owner proponents of the medallion bill
say putting companies in charge would
benefit riders but a 2010 study by the
city's Department of Finance argued the
opposite cities with medallions have
fares that are 25 percent higher when
you're creating a system where the
medallion owner can create artificial
scarcity in service riders are going to
have less cabs available to them these
big cab companies they will take charge
of everything the man behind the
medallion proposal is Jerry Shafer he's
a local taxi cab magnate who runs a
bunch of companies that are
headquartered here in the River Terrace
neighborhood in Northeast Washington DC
up front he'll get a whole bunch of the
medallions when they're offered for sale
at $10,000 apiece that'll be able to
turn those into real cash by either
renting the cabs out to local drivers or
selling the medallions at a profit
Schafer hired lobbyists John ray to
write the medallion bill ray has worked
as a lawyer defending representative
Harry Thomas in an ongoing corruption
suit and it was Thomas who sponsored
Ray's bill in the DC City Council
another backer of the medallion bill
councilmember Marion Barry
the former mayor best known for being
caught smoking crack in a hotel room
with
his girlfriend console memories Barry
and thomas-john ray and Jerry Schaefer
all declined our request for an
interview the last time a medallion bill
was proposed it was later withdrawn by
councilmember Jim Graham after his chief
of staff was caught by the FBI accepting
a bribe from a representative of the
taxi industry we need to stand up in a
letter published in The Washington Post
lobbyist john ray argued that because
the cab industry is open entry and
unregulated it's been susceptible to
corruption but in practice the DC taxi
Commission which currently regulates the
industry has its own history of
corruption and the Commission is so wary
of scrutiny that when reporter Pete
Tucker snapped this photo on his cell
phone at a recent public meeting he was
dragged out and arrested reason TV
producer Jim Epstein captured Tucker's
arrest on his mobile phone later Epstein
was also arrested after resisting
attempts by the taxi Commission and u.s.
Park Police to confiscate his camera
phone when Tucker was arrested cab
drivers stormed out of the meeting in
protest
we will continue to struggle for the
continuation of the guarantee of our
rights to earn our living we naturally
when we smell it and we are not going to
take this stinking thing smell again we
want to be free entrepreneurs in this
town
period